doctors transphobic if they refer to
their patients who have a penis and they
come in for a prostate exam as a male is
that doctor hate speaking is that an act
of aggression I think if that doctor
misgenders their patient then yeah they
are being transphobic okay well my mind
has not changed I tried to find some
common ground I'm sorry that we didn't
listening I'm sorry sorry that you feel
that way yeah thank you medison I'm not
going to shake your I figured I hate to
ruin your like polite discourse but you
thank you thank you for putting that on
display for the whole world you're
scum okay we talk an act of
aggression her touching me when I didn't
want her to touch me that's not assault
that's actually battery so it's actually
worse than using the improper pronoun
but I'm cool with it